Here is one of the digital images that we
have just been looking at and on the right
we can see some of its pertinent details.
Now we can determine the total number of bytes
in the image by multiplying the image width
by the image height by three. The number three
comes from the fact that for every pixel in
the image we need to represent the amount
of red, green and blue. And each of those
is represented by a single byte. And when
we compute this product we see that something
like 21 million bytes of information is in
this image. However, on disk the image only
occupies 3.7 megabytes, so the number of bytes
on disk is way less then the number of colour
pixels that there are in the original image.
If we take the ratio of these two numbers,
we see that the number of bytes required to
store the image in the file on disk is a very
small fraction of the total number of bytes
required to represent all the coloured pixels
in the image, and this comes about because
this image has been compressed.
Now all images contain a large number of pixel
data and we want to make the file size as
small as we possibly can. That means then
we can fit more images into the same amount
of disk. There are two fundamentally different
approaches to image compression. The first
is Lossless compression, and what this does
is exploit redundancy or recurring patterns
in the image and codes them very efficiently,
so they require overall less space. And this
is in stark contrast to Lossy compression,
the most common example of which is JPEG compression. And what lossy compression does is exploit
the fact that the human vision system is far
from perfect, and that there is some information
that you can remove from the image in such
a way that the human observer does not notice
very much change. So some of the problems
with the human vision system is we are not
very good at noticing very fine detail. We
are not as good at resolving the differences
between colours as we are at resolving the
differences between different intensities.
And our colour sensitivity actually depends
on the sorts of colours that we are looking
at. So we can exploit these bugs in the human
visual system in order to remove information
that we wouldn’t notice anyway and make
the files much smaller.
Here is an image of our favourite robot and
on disk this image occupies 480 kilobytes.
If we observe this little region within the
robot and we zoom in on that what we can see
is that it looks pretty good, we can see the
edges are fairly sharp, and there is some
interesting colour gradations there. Now this
image has only been modestly compressed, it
is 82% of the original image size. But if
we start to increase the amount of compression,
we are throwing away additional information,
we see the image starts to become quite seriously
degraded when we zoom in and look at it very
closely. So with the very high level of compression
the image is only occupying twelve per cent
of the original storage, so we have made massive
savings in the disk space required, but the
image is starting to look fairly poor when
we zoom in on it. And if we zoom in even further
we can see that it has become quite blocky,
quite quantised, and there are many fewer
colours here than there are in the original
image.
All of these images have the same number of
pixels, but the actual file size varies. This
image as we mentioned before is 3.7 megabytes
long. This crocodile is only 2.9 megabytes
long. The bird picture
3.8 megabytes. The size of an image after
it has been compressed is a function of how
much information is in that image.